Fans have been desperate for a follow-up
to Quentin Tarantino's seminal film "Pulp
Fiction" since it hit the silver
screen, but thirty years later,
it seems unlikely that we'll ever see a sequel.
"Pulp Fiction" was the second feature film made
by writer-director Quentin Tarantino. He's now
closing in on his tenth, and in 2023,
he celebrated his 60th birthday. Sadly,
Tarantino has often talked up the notion
of retiring after both of those milestones.
Unfortunately for die-hard "Pulp Fiction"
fans, that tenth film isn't going to be a
follow-up to the 1994 classic. Instead, it's
a project called "The Movie Critic," which
is about a 1970s critic who reviews films for a
porno magazine. If it really is his final film,
that kills off quite a few potential Tarantino
projects. At various points in his career,
he's floated ideas like a gangster-style
"Star Trek" movie, a third "Kill Bill" entry,
and a movie about Black soldiers during
World War II. So assuming that Tarantino
sticks to his guns when it comes to feature
film retirement, we won't be seeing any of
those movies play out on the big screen. In other
words, the time has passed for "Pulp Fiction 2."
Other persistent issues have long dogged
"Pulp Fiction 2": ownership and rights. As
it turns out, it may have been tough for
Tarantino to even legally make a sequel
to his own film. The director owns the
copyright of the "Pulp Fiction" script,
but Miramax owns the finished film. Evidently,
when Tarantino tried to make "Pulp Fiction" NFTs,
he wound up in a lawsuit with Miramax that
ended in 2022. If just making non-fungible
tokens was that contentious, imagine how it
might've hampered the making of another movie.
Over the last three decades, "Pulp Fiction"
writer-director Quentin Tarantino has openly
discussed at least three films that would've
expanded the film's universe. In the 1990s,
following the back-to-back successes of "Reservoir
Dogs" and "Pulp Fiction," Tarantino toyed with
the idea of linking the two films in a new
project called "Double V Vega." In that movie,
Michael Madsen and John Travolta would've
reprised their respective "Reservoir Dogs"
and "Pulp Fiction" roles of Vic Vega and
Vincent Vega — because they're brothers.
Essentially a prequel to both movies, it
would have been about the Vega siblings
hanging out in Amsterdam, a trip that Vincent
Vega alludes to in his "Pulp Fiction" opening
monologue. Tarantino never went anywhere
with "Double V Vega," which was also
billed as "The Vega Brothers," other than that
premise. And given that 30 years have passed,
it's probably too late for Madsen and Travolta
to play younger versions of their characters.
As for other possibilities,
there's a scene in "Pulp Fiction" in
which Jules Winnfield tells Vincent,
"I'm just going to walk the Earth."
"Whatchu you mean 'walk the earth'?"
“You know, like Caine in 'Kung Fu.' Walk from
place to place, meet people, get in adventures."
Tarantino thought about making that single line
of dialog into a whole movie, but he told Movie
Nerds that it never moved beyond the idea realm.
As for the third potential film, while promoting
"Kill Bill" in 2003, Tarantino told Aotearoa
News that a sequel was stirring. He said,
"There's an idea I have. Bottom line,
the studio wants it, the fans want it. I'm
sure I can compromise somewhere. It'd be
my way of apologizing for never getting
'Vega Brothers' off the ground, I guess."
Nevertheless, that movie never did get produced.
Due to the events of the first "Pulp Fiction"
and circumstances affecting the cast's ability
or willingness to participate in the
present day, any follow-up film set in
the same cinematic universe couldn't serve as
a direct sequel. For example, Vincent Vega,
portrayed by John Travolta in the film, doesn't
make it out of "Pulp Fiction" alive, while Bruce
Willis, who played rogue boxer Butch Coolidge,
retired from acting after developing dementia.
As for the rest of the cast, it seems like
it might take Tarantino a lot of work to
convince Samuel L. Jackson to reprise his
role of hitman Jules Winnfield. In 2022,
Tarantino derisively discussed the
"Marvel-ization of Hollywood" on the
podcast "2 Bears, 1 Cave." Jackson portrays Nick
Fury throughout the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
took umbrage at his "Pulp Fiction" director's
comments, firing back at him on "The View."
As for Uma Thurman, who played Mia Wallace,
her relationship with Tarantino has been
rocky. In 2018, she told The New York Times
that she nearly died in a car stunt gone awry
during the filming of "Kill Bill," a
stunt the director reportedly forced
her to do. And allegedly, Tarantino spat on
her and choked her for two separate scenes.
Thurman has said that she forgave Tarantino for
the car incident after the director apologized.
And it's very likely the filmmaker could
patch things up with Jackson over their
Marvel feud. Still, it seems like there
might be some friction between Tarantino
and the key players involved. So even if
a "Pulp Fiction 2" were a possibility,
getting the band back together might
be pretty difficult at this point.
Writing, directing, producing, and releasing a
movie, particularly a sequel to a 30-year-old
film, is a difficult and complicated task. It
might be more pragmatic and easier for Tarantino
to release the long-rumored and often-speculated
"Pulp Fiction" follow-up in another format,
like the written word, a medium Tarantino
has actively explored in recent years.
In 2021, he published "Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood," a novelization and expansion of his
2019 film of the same name. And according to Dave
Poland, in the 2010s, Tarantino began writing a
literary spinoff of his "Django Unchained" project
called "Django in White Hell," which evolved into
"The Hateful Eight." However, he did give Django
life on the page, pairing the gunfighting hero
up with one of the world's most famous masked
vigilantes in the comic book "Django/Zorro."
And while these aren't real sequels, other
artists and professionals have revisited
the world of "Pulp Fiction"
in their projects. In 2023,
Deadline reported that production had started
on "Stealing Pulp Fiction," a heist movie from
director-writer Danny Turkiewicz about a
group of friends who try to abscond with
Tarantino's copy of the original 35-millimeter
"Pulp Fiction" film reels. And back in 2014,
Harvey Keitel reprised his role as the
inscrutable and effective "Pulp Fiction"
fixer Winston Wolfe in a series of commercials
for U.K. insurance company Direct Line.